behind these doors is a giant surprise
huge
for the past year chan and i have been
working on a little project and when
these doors open you'll be getting the
very first look ever at the lost city it
feels better than i thought it would i
know i thought the same thing i was
worried too because these doors are
really just a metaphor for an adventure
oh my god while you're still in it i
know it's crazy all right you want to
get to it yeah we give to you
the lost city
oh hey guys
do you guys know there's nothing back
there daniel
yeah we know oh no daniel
the doors are just a metaphor for
adventure oh sorry i screwed it up that
was nice though finishing each other's
sentences
wow all right
so what um i don't know what do you want
to do what was the last part of um are
you hungry i think yeah are we done
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete
delete listen loretta we need you to
promote your new book on the lost city
you can't spend your life in the bathtub
drinking chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
mcmahon
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up that's like oh
my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your
oh no
loretta sage is missing i'm gonna rescue
her i just want her to think of me as
more than a cover mom living dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm sort
of like crossfit
i have snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off give me a second are you
filming suckers
feels like there's more holy mother of
god ah they're just sucking on my butt
like a big old jamba juice
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh
oh
[Music]
the red sage getting you out of here why
are you so awesome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
[Music]
you